[Music]
she leaves it all behind her
seven decades of state visits
audiences with prime ministers
and the palace balcony
where she would wave to these crowds
now somber watching in silence
on the queen's coffin was her crown
behind it a wreath of pine from the
gardens at balmoral and lavender from
the grounds of windsor
following the queen the new king
and all the senior members of the royal
household they entered the most famous
street of royal ceremonies
never has the mal been so full
and so quiet
a family's grief and the nations there
for the world to see
halfway along the avenue two statues
gazed on the queen's father king george
vi and her mother not since her death
twenty years ago has the country seen a
procession to a laying in state
so much has changed
it's 25 years since prince william and
his brother made this same walk behind
the coffin of their mother aged 15 and
12
something harry would later say was
inappropriate for someone so young
as the procession passed on to horse
guards parade
there was applause
during the 40-minute journey to the
palace of westminster
big ben told at minute intervals
the procession made its way past the
cenotaph where some of the families
saluted the memorial to fallen soldiers
an hour before the event the city of
london released a statement warning that
viewing areas were full
some who traveled long distances were
turned away and many could only get a
limited view
the crowds back to the barriers are
meters deep and everybody here has their
own story with the queen which is
collectively coming to an end and that
is the pull for so many people just to
witness this momentous final chapter to
be able to say they were here they saw
it
it's when the um the uh casket went past
with the crown on top and you thought
everyone was gassed a bit it was like a
bit it's a funny feeling i suppose yeah
yeah did gasp
that's what it was like everybody did it
at the same time for me it was emotional
and i was a bit somber
and now i'm getting a bit emotional so
yeah it was
part of the history i was i'm part of
the history so it's nice to be there
party
slow
march
the queen's company first battalion
grenadier guards carried the queen from
the gun carriage to westminster hall
their commander-in-chief
also a military wife mother and
grandmother and the first female royal
to join the armed services
here princess catherine and the duchess
of sussex joined their husbands
archbishop of canterbury read the
opening prayer
oh god
the maker and redeemer of all mankind
grant us
with thy servant queen elizabeth king
charles faced the coffin in this last
moment with his mother until the funeral
on monday
a double tap from the officer of the
watch signaled the start of the first
vigil kept by four officers from the
household cavalry
while outside the queue began to stretch
down the thames across it and back on
itself the public in waiting
and they will wait and wait for hours on
end for this last chance to spend just a
moment with their queen
and say goodbye each in their own way
jason farrell sky news